(dubstep)
- I'm Dr. Armond, California's
premier dog plastic surgeon.
Do you--
- Dr. Ar-Armond?
- Armond, mm-hmm.
- (Armond drowns out sound)
think that's more romantic.
- What does that mean?
- I'm making a sexual
innuendo to you.
I'm not sure if the
sexual chemistry's there,
but I feel like I've finally
found a real partner.
It feels like Denise
has been going
for K-9s when she
really deserves a K-10.
(harp plays)
I'm ready.
- Just took an Ambien,
you got 20 minutes
before it's non-consensual.
- That seems a bit
passive-aggressive.
You're trying to get a reaction
out of me, but you won't.
(yells)
(loud licking)
I'm feeling a bit
nauseous right now.
Do you want to press pause?
Or have you made a dog-cision?
All in a day's work
for Dr. Armond.
(dubstep)